hi I'm Ryan and tonight I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for bricks mansion
is the story of the Channel 4 News team
and it's brick Tamland home get it
because it's Briggs mansion uh yeah this
is actually Paul Walker's last movie
then again seems like Paul Walker keeps
coming up with a lot of last movies
lately it really does suck that the guy
did pass away and he was a cool dude
like that was I I personally did not
find his talent that amazing but he was
always charming and he was always very
likable like even when his performance
was like not always there were times
where he was great but there were signs
really like I don't know about that man
and when he was in that stage of I don't
know about that man he was so very
likable you know and it's rare where for
you like actors just have that natural
charisma that even if they're not doing
so great they'll still be very uh you'll
still be very appeal to them you know a
movie I did like foot Paul Walker that I
don't think a lot of people liked but I
really I like Joyride a lot of that
joyride was cool you see Paul Walker's
ass in that movie man you see that I was
like damn is Paul Walker's ass get a
really good ass but what I'm excited for
about this last movie of Paul Walker is
the fact that people seem to really be
drawn to the movie itself you know like
sometimes an actor passes away then a
movie comes out later and because of the
sentimental attachment people then go
watch it but not because they think the
movie looks that great this film
everyone's talking about it like it's
the [ __ ] you know I don't know anything
about I don't know what it's about I
don't really know who else is in it the
fact that I'm hearing that people are
saying oh this actually looks like a
really cool movie I I'm excited to see
this trailer man all right PW let's
watch your trailer buddy right all right
here we go here we go
oh snap
he's like one of those parkour guys is
that Oprah detective there's a situation
that demands the best of the best
brick mansions it's so dangerous we
built a wall around it Oh brick mansion
gets us and other leaders darlings you
don't have the city hostage oh he can
handle it
Adam the window inside we've got someone
who knows brick mansions the convict is
my partner I got the plan to get us in
us first chance you get what are you
gonna do put a bomb back on him good
luck to you whoa he pointlessly flipped
on that wall
look this [ __ ] man or look besson
whatever like his movies I still like a
good amount of his movies you know how
does Luke besan go for making the
professional to making lockout anyway
this isn't about him that movie looks
pretty [ __ ] sweet actually it's got
that cheese it's got that it's got that
flare about it you know it's sure it's a
little stereotypical kinda has a plot
reminisce and walk out now that I think
about it kind of kind of you know this
one place I got infiltrated and stuff
but I loved the whole thing with
incorporating parkour I think this
what's called I'd be something a total
idiot right now
by that thing where they you know do
cool flips and [ __ ] in the park I'm not
explaining this well if you don't know
what it is look it up it's all the cool
[ __ ] they were doing in the trailer
where they're just running around and
everything when they're doing all those
awesome sweet moves they're putting into
fight scenes and action scenes and stuff
and I always thought it would be really
cool if you'd be like a movie where it
was based around that I didn't know this
movie was incorporating that as their
style and you know what it's a really
cool unique style and I'm excited see on
the big screen it doesn't really matter
if the movie sucks or not what matters
is is that [ __ ] gonna be [ __ ] cool
and it
is we're in that's what we said oh that
is too much